they want us to pay for our own raisins
that we grew we have to buy them back it
it's hurting a small grower and I
believe that the government wants by
doing these things is trying to get rid
of all the small growers don't mess with
what we produce
don't take a percentage let us do what
we want with our own crop Marvin and
Laura Horne make raisins they've done it
for more than three decades they plant
the seeds water the crops tie the vines
harvest the fruit and sundry the grapes
and paper trays they even package and
market the finished product
my wife has been on the farm all over
life she's a fourth-generation farmer we
were married in 1968 we bought our first
farm my parents bought their first 20
acres on their own away from my
grandparents and we literally the three
of us did all the farm work I went out
and I tied vines I rolled trays we
picked grapes we did everything and I
just hate to see it just given away you
know it means a lot to me
every single raisin produced and sold in
the u.s. is raised dried and harvested
by California farmers like horns
the state is famous for its raisins
worldwide but every year something
strange happens to California's raisin
farmers the government seizes a portion
of their harvest and doesn't pay them a
cent for it it was a theft the reserve
was nothing but highway robbery
as it evolved as all organizations
evolved into a bureaucracy a few people
get in control of it and they mastermind
it for their benefit not for the benefit
of the farmer the government calls it a
marketing order
it's a vestige of old depression here
are price controls intended to keep crop
prices high enough for farmers to be
guaranteed a steady annual income first
elected members of something called the
raisin Administrative Committee decide
what raisin prices should be at harvest
time
the USDA forces farmers to set aside a
reserve of raisins that cannot be sold
hence driving up raising prices later
the raisin packing companies can sell
the raisins from the reserve pool
overseas that dirt cheap prices set by
the government or funnel them into
government school lunch programs at low
or no cost the packers make money the
schools are happy but the farmers make
next to nothing farmers were always
supposed to get some money back from the
confiscated raisins but his profit
margins on the reserves dwindled over
the years so did payments to the farmers
it got so bad that in 2003 raisin
farmers received zero dollars in return
for the 47 percent of the crop that had
been taken from them when that 47
percent I couldn't manage any more with
that either I had to go borrow money
because everything from my grandfather
was paid and I had to go borrow money
you borrow money you never get out of it
you're dead so I sold that to 20 acre
pieces just to stay to survive there are
already farmers that have lost their
land
maybe that's no getting it back you
can't work
for a whole year and then give 47% of
what you made away and still plan on
keeping that business afloat the horns
had had enough instead of handing their
crop over to politically connected
Packers they began packing and selling
their own raisins and they refused to
hand any of it over to the USDA and
that's when the government cracked down
they took their original inspection
reports and made an estimate well this
is how many reasons you you owe us
because you you pack these many raisins
and you got you got to pay us and in
addition that we're gonna find you
because you didn't give them to us we're
facing still around 700,000 and fines
probably with interest and everything
close to a million and a half unable to
pay hundreds of thousands of dollars of
fines the horns and other small farmers
banded together to fight the USDA in
court
representatives from the USDA and the
raisin Administrative Committee declined
to participate in this video race of
mark in the orders diabolical Brian
Layton is a former federal prosecutor
turned defense attorney who is fed up
with what he saw as the government's
overzealous enforcement of farming
regulations they were filing complaints
against farmers for violating prorate
and oranges not complying with the
nectarine peach and plum marketing or
anything what are you guys doing you're
not doing important what do you believe
the farmers alone what is this
Layton took the horns case all the way
to the US Supreme Court after the Ninth
Circuit decided that the case before
them was a matter of unpaid fines and
not a constitutional issue they turn
around and ruled against us said no
takings it would be one thing if USDA
marched onto the horns property and took
47% their crop but they didn't do that
all that all they did is say if you're
gonna sell them we own 47% of them lots
of taking the Fifth Amendment says that
private property shall not be taken for
public use without just compensation the
horns argued that because the government
took their property they had a right to
be paid for it but
government said that they never
physically took the horns property and
we're simply fining them for disobeying
farming regulations property rights are
bundles of rights the ability to possess
keep give away sell ownership when they
take title to your raisins you can do
none of that in an I know ruling the
Supreme Court decided that the horns did
have a legitimate takings case and now
after nearly a decade the Ninth Circuit
will hear the case and decide whether or
not the USDA's actions constitute a
taking of property
now we're off and running now they have
to decide it and if they decided against
us we just know the Supreme Court is
gonna take it again because this thought
this is just crazy
47% of your crop don't mess with what we
produce
don't take a percentage let us do what
we want with our own crop I don't think
they have a right to tell us what we
have to do with it I didn't choose the
fight all I chose to do was pack and
market my own raisins they're the ones
that picked the fight USDA and the
raisin administrative order picked the
fight not me
you